I remember in Cujo do you remember that
I just saw it and I didn't know I was
yes it starts saying I want my daddy and
I said all right I'll get to your father
right and then you start crying you kind
of go I'll catching your father's like
you're almost you're emotional like but
you couldn't take it anymore it's
awesome you came to me the next day and
said D we need you to look at the
dailies from yesterday it's such a
powerful scene but we think we might cut
it because we're afraid people won't
like you
didn't so I never watched dailies but I
said okay
and I went to Dan Blatt our beloved
producer and I said Dan if you cut that
senior crazy there's not a parent in the
world that hasn't felt that moment
and they kept it in and it was the most
well reviewed scene in the movie
that movie you know you know what's
funny I swear to God I wouldn't I
wouldn't bring it up if I didn't
because I didn't mean it
um I have horror movie Nights every
Tuesday night with my friends it's the
guys and we're watching our movies and I
go oh you've seen a lot of me oh yeah oh
yeah I go have you guys ever seen Cujo
and they're like no I'm like are you
are you kidding me you've
never seen Cujo and they go yeah all
right let's watch I go all right cool
look I remember this movie being intense
and I loved it it may not hold up I
don't know but let's watch it
and everybody unanimous it was
boy did it hold up yeah and it was you
know why it was because of the acting
you that little Danny oh my God
unbelievable
thank God I got that kid for that role
because it was just him and me and him
and me I couldn't believe he was the
things that he was doing like almost
dead well and what was funny was because
I'm you know it's why I play mothers I
get very motherly with all these kids
and I said okay Danny now
tomorrow we're gonna do the scene where
you have to do the seizure
so do you want to rehearse it are you
afraid of any he says oh that happened
to me when I was little you want to see
and he goes right into it and I went I
so do not have to worry about this
freaking kid at all really yeah he he
was
just an old soul how much did you hate
being in that car and I if I never see
another Pinto again in my life it will
be too soon how how many days do you
think you filmed oh we were we were in
the pinto half of half of the shooting
once you hit the halfway point the rest
of it in the pinto yeah and a lot of
people think you know we were dying in
the heat we were actually really really
cold because it was in Northern
California in November and December
my God and they used like how many
they use the mechanical dog they used a
bunches okay I read stuff but I don't
know if it's true okay yeah there were
13 dogs that played Cujo
all trained to go after toys Saint
Bernards
because
you could you can't overwork a dog you
can overwork an actor
and then they treated me for exhaustion
for three weeks after that film but
there were 13 dogs that played Cujo
uh Gary Morgan was our wonderful
stuntman and he didn't do that much in
in the movie the real dogs did almost
every shot you know what's crazy about
that movie as much as you care for you
guys
you really feel bad for the dog yeah
like that dog is a mess all the
that they put on it and you just like
especially if you're a dog lover he saw
these really oh my God yeah but Cujo
dies you're like it wasn't kuja's fault
he had he had he had rabies and it was
like yeah his mine was gone and that's
why we had to
we had to really create so much Terror
and and horrible things that Cujo had
done
in order to get to the that last scene
where he's coming through the door
through the broken glass you know so the
audience goes yeah shoot him because
Danny's gonna die you have to do that
right that's amazing it's amazing how
that moment you have to have it you know
in the book Danny dies
and Stephen oh yeah yeah I knew that
yeah Stephen King
um call Dan Blatt and said thank God you
didn't kill the kid at the end you
couldn't do that he never got more hate
mail in his life than when he killed
Danny at the end of Kuja really that's
what he's that's what I was told